. This is very exciting, but also a little
bit depressing because it's not going to pass
the Senate.
House and Senate Democrats have introduced
legislation to make Washington, DC a state,
the fifty first state of the United States.
This is something we've been talking about
for months and months.
The measure was reintroduced in the House
by a delegate, Eleanor Holmes Norton.
She's a Democrat who represents the District
of Columbia.
And the Senate version was introduced by Senator
Tom Carper from Delaware as of Tuesday evening.
Norton says she has more than 200 co-sponsors
in the House, but it appears as though there
is no chance whatsoever that this is going
to pass in the Senate.
Democrats control the Senate with the 50/50
split and Kamala Harris as a tie breaking
vote.
But Democrats would need to overcome a filibuster
on this issue, which requires 60 votes.
This is not something you can pass via budget
reconciliation, meaning Democrats need to
find ten Republicans willing to vote yes.
Washington, D.C. should meet should be a state.
Republican lawmakers for a long time have
opposed Washington, D.C. statehood.
As you and I have talked about before, representation
in Washington, D.C. would likely be overwhelmingly
Democratic, meaning two additional Democratic
senators.
And that is not something that Republicans
want to see.
Now, of course, the reality is that on the
merits, this makes obvious sense, even by
Republicans so-called values if the Republican
Party were actually principled.
This should be a unanimous vote in favor of
Washington, D.C., being a state.
Washington, D.C. is being taxed without representation.
Big government is ruling over these Washington,
D.C. folks without them having a voice.
If this were Utah that didn't have two senators,
Republicans would have voted, I don't know,
decades ago and said, oh, Utah absolutely
must have two senators.
But the difference is Utah's very red and
Washington, D.C. is very blue.
But if the principle here is that people deserve
representation, you're paying taxes.
Why do some taxpayers get Senate representation
and other taxpayers do not?
It is because they know who lives in Washington,
D.C. and they know how Washington, D.C. would
vote.
And so it's not really about principles or
democracy anymore.
If you are an American, you should have at
least one member of the House representing
you and two senators.
How is this even a debate?
Well, it's a debate because of the false claims
of values and principles when it's convenient
to them for Republicans and abandoning those
same principles when it no longer is convenient.
Washington, D.C. has more than 100000 more
people living in it than the entire state
of Wyoming.
OK, if Washington, D.C. was a state, they
would have their own National Guard.
They could have responded on January 6th without
having to depend on all of these other players
to say, fine, fine, fine, we're going to send
National Guard.
Washington, D.C. is the 20th largest city
in the United States.
That's not even the D.C. metro.
That's Washington, D.C. itself.
They pay federal taxes.
They pay local you know, they pay all sorts
of taxes, but they have no senators.
It is absolutely ridiculous.
And I hope that Joe Biden will actually make
this an issue.
There have been questions about is how much
of a of an issue is this going to be for the
Biden Harris administration?
The people of Washington, D.C., deserve to
be represented just as much as the people
of other states.
We know why Republicans aren't for it.
It is not for any principle other than the
principle of we are hypocrites and just do
things that favor our party.
That's the only principle that Republicans
are abiding by and adhering to when they say,
yeah, we don't think Washington, D.C. should
be a state.
Now, we've talked also about Puerto Rico,
Puerto Rico, I believe both D.C. and Puerto
Rico should be states.
If Puerto Rico wants to be a state.
Of course, the difference is politically and
again, for me, it's the principle.
So I don't care about this.
It's less clear that Puerto Rico would probably
not be unanimously Democratic and has representation.
It's there's a larger conservative contingent
in Puerto Rico.
I would expect that there would probably be
at least one member of the House that is a
Republican that would win in Puerto Rico Senate.
I don't know.
But the principle here makes me come to no
other conclusion than D.C. should be a state.
Puerto Rico should be a state.
Now, I know people will say, well, what about
American Samoa?
What about Guam?
OK, we're dealing with Puerto Rico and Washington,
DC right now.
Send me your thoughts about this.
What could convince ten, ten Republicans in
the Senate to say, yeah, I will vote for D.C.
statehood?
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll have continued coverage of this on our
Instagram page at The David Pakman Show.
And you can follow me on Instagram as well
at David Pakman, The
David Pakman Show at